we're gonna go back in time we're gonna
we're gonna pull up this next article
because i'm willing to uh trigger the
internet once again
this is a story i covered from the new
york post women are struggling to find
men who make as much money as they do
yep and i gave a very simple hypothesis
and people did not like it because it
was an offensive hypothesis
i don't care the hypothesis goes as such
if there is a 30 year old woman who's
working a job
and she makes 75k a year and there is a
30 year old man
who works a similar job and makes 75k a
year
the woman looked at the guy and says
that's my peer that's who i want to be
with or
someone who makes more money but that
guy who's 30 making 75k a year is not
looking at a 30 year old woman
he's looking at a 22 year old woman okay
cupid data showed us this
that no matter what age the guy was he
would message 22 year old women
yeah guilty as charged and i got i got
it hello except for me the numbers no no
no
no
45. i'm not a fan that's not for me of
24 year old girls i'm not
i mean the idea of like i guess hooking
up with a 22 year old sure i get
but and when i'm talking about a
legitimate relationship where you
actually want to have a life companion
have a family
i think it's absurd to be a 35 year old
man reaching out to 22 year olds yeah
she'd have to be really evolved
yeah that's and that's and that's why i
said 20 22 no 24
but even even 24 26 i've had three
significant relationships in my life and
each one of them began with a girl who
was 24.
when i was 24 when i was 30 well
i was 40. let me let me read this let me
read this okay the new york post writes
the country is facing a crisis of broke
dudes
according to new research from cornell
university and its left successful
single
successful ladies single and disgruntled
i wonder if they misunderstood the data
when they ask women are you finding men
your age
who have money i think the issue is it's
not so much
that the dudes are broke but that even
if a guy is 30
and he's making 25k less than the woman
he's not going to choose a woman who's
30.
no the problem is is the women are
making too much money
okay because it's ruined evolution
it's ruined everything that is built
into a woman's brain
a woman wants to marry a guy who's
lateral
or above and if a woman makes so much
money
it reduces her pool of available men the
fault of their not being enough men
is the fact that women make too much
money yep boom done and the story
you think you you so you're saying this
is this is they're getting what they've
asked for
i think hahaha live in that i think by
the way i've
got a young girl at home myself boom get
rich
i i don't i don't i don't know if i
agree with that yeah i agree that no it
changes it's all about a dynamic
if the girls were making 35 000 a year
and that same guy was still making 70
000
a year she'd be like there's men there's
just eligible men all over the place but
now she's making the same as the guy and
she's like i don't want him but i don't
think that's absolute i think that
if there was a guy making 50k a year and
one would make him 150 he'd be like this
is great
like we're gonna have tons of money
actually uh pew has done a number of
studies on this very thing
and women say that they want to date a
man and marry a man that makes more
money than that but everybody wants to
marry
up no i don't want to marry up okay why
would i want to marry a woman that makes
more money and works harder than i do
and spends more time i didn't say that i
didn't say that
mary up how are we calculating do you
want to marry like a woman who sleeps in
the gutter
so it doesn't have to be money it's like
life she had a heart of gold and was
willing to take care of my house and was
kind of hot and good with kids
i don't care what she does as long as
she's going to stop doing that
and she's going to start taking care of
the family wow
truth true story may i interest true
story this is a societal
difference no actually this is evolution
this is me as a man speaking to women as
women this is not
this is not crazy things go ahead i
think that jack is correct
i believe that this is known as hyper
hypergamy
hypergamy hypergamy so i have read that
men become more depressed when their
spouses make more money than of course
they do because it's not
status this is not a case of just having
a bunch of money this is very much about
who earns the money and for guys it is
very important to
make more money than their spouse and i
don't i'm not going to say that's
materialistic i'm just going to say
that's the way that it is and this is
the data that i've read
this depresses men to make less of their
spouses this increase the risk of
divorce
yes like it's actually a problem for
guys look men
are hardwired to build create provide
and protect and if you take away
the things that we do then people are
going to feel terrible
this this this i'm glad you brought this
up because dude i've been writing and
thinking about these issues for 10 years
man
and i just spent two hours on benjamin
boyce's channel
ranting about this stuff in my most
lucid state as a matter of fact please
check it out
i was on a roll talking about this this
is the chickens coming home to roost
in 148 out of 150 of the top
metropolitan areas in the wa
in america entry-level women make more
money than their entry-level counterpart
males right and they're unhappy about it
they've all been herded into college
saddled with debt they get good jobs
they look around
the men are just the same as them
there's nothing exciting about that
there's no hopeful future in that
there's no this guy's gonna build create
protect and provide for me i can already
build create protect and provide for
myself
says the woman and that's why tim i
think you're off on this
i think that the natural age difference
builds in
this dynamic where a man and a woman
could be just as smart
just as interested in the world just as
capable but by virtue
of the age difference the man is more
established
the woman is less established you have
that status difference
the man can provide and protect the
woman can nurture and love and caretake
and people are happier that way i
strongly recommend men
don't get married until you're 35 until
your career is established you got your
money
and then definitely look for a woman
who's about 10 years younger than you
that is a hundred percent
what was the pure research you're
talking about so i'm trying to find it
pew research uh
consistent studies that show women uh
prefer to marry a man that makes either
as much money as them or more
or more never less nevertheless
i cannot i will find it i will find it
for you i will find it
i can find though this story this this
study from 2017
americans see men as the financial
providers even as women's contributions
grow
even as women are trying to make more
and more salaries men are still
viewed as the breadwinners yeah as they
should be that's the way we're designed
that's why we have testosterone that's
why we have big muscles that's why we
can smash things
that's why women are soft and sweet and
they like to cuddle things and they feed
them from their breasts
because they literally give other humans
life
that's why we're that's how we're
designed it's what our hormones do
oh oh this is crazy uh we're getting
into this on this show jack murphy what
are you doing we're gonna get in so much
trouble
let's do it from market watch may 27
2019 this one thing
in your marriage increases the risk of
divorce by 33 percent
oh what is it women making more money
than men
that's the image the financial gender
balance within marriage seems to be
changing at a faster pace
they say it could be a race to finish in
more ways than one
when wives earn more than their husbands
some men
just can't handle it that's what's up
neither can the women
nobody can nobody likes only jessica
valenti out there gets off on making
more money than her husband
only jessica valenti gets off on there
thinking her husband is at home and he's
so sexy
he's so powerful and masculine he cut
the crust off the kids sandwiches
and he wears his slippers in his health
robe all day only jessica valenti thinks
like that i've i've
i've seen uh and if they don't i'm sorry
and if the women
give lip service to this notion they're
lying well i wonder if it's about money
or
because i know because i don't know if
it's about money like oh it's about
status and power
status and power because if a guy
becomes the president he doesn't make a
lot of money
but he's super powerful he will have and
women love that
it's about power and status and there's
no faulting women for this
women historically do not have physical
power
right the way that women have physical
powers by proxy
we are the neck that turns by making men
do things for them using cunning
guile beauty caretaking nurturing and
delivering children
men are proxy power for women this is
this is the way
you survive in the caves in the
wilderness
they can't go around beating the you
know beating up the bears and they can't
go around beating up the the hostile
groups that are going to take us over
so you got to get a man to do it for you
how do you get amanda do it for you you
look cute you look pretty you take care
of [ __ ]
here's what they say they say the risk
of divorce is nearly 33 percent higher
when a husband isn't working full time
according to money work and marital
stability
assessing change in the gender
determinants of divorce a 2016 study
of more than 6 300 couples by alexandra
killerwald
professor of sociology at harvard
university quote
for marriages formed after 1975 husbands
lack of full-time employment is
associated with higher risk of divorce
expectations of wives homemaking may
have eroded
but the husband breadwinner norm
persists the apparent disconnect may be
due to peer pressure
or attitudes passed down from parents
another theory through evolution
a persistent glass ceiling for women at
work may encourage men to believe they
should also be the highest earners at
home
persistent one thing they never talk
about though is
it there's always an excuse but it's
always the man's fault
of course it is because everything is
the man's fault period this sounds like
it's like a
lack of purpose issue with if someone
doesn't have a full-time job maybe
they're
missing purpose in their life and they
become much less attractive that is a
separate issue but yes you're exactly
right people don't have a mission or a
purpose or an expression of values
that's unrelated
to their source of income and people
have terrible horrible lives when their
values and their mission and their
purpose
aren't aligned with the things that they
have to do to earn money i would even
like to see
independently wealthy people that
inherit a bunch of money that don't have
jobs
and see their rates of success in
marriage because i think that would be
low also
if you don't have something that you
love outside of yourself if those two
things aren't necessarily the case you
can be born with a lot of money and have
passions you know
building no meat or but my point is or
whatever it's not that women or men
seek money in their partner it's that
they seek drive ambition status and
power or potential for it no what they
seek is
differential power that's what they both
parties seek
what do you mean by that because you can
be a broke-ass dude
and find a woman that looks up to you
who because she's broker
right this is relative power yes it's
about relative power
it's about relative power and relative
status a woman that doesn't have a job
doesn't care doesn't have any education
latches on to a guy that's got a minimum
wage job
and and has a room in a house somewhere
well she's moving up in the world
right it's all about relative power and
that's why the more okay look
more women graduate high school more
women apply
to go to college more women graduate
college
more women get hired out of school for
jobs women make more money than men
coming out of school
women live longer are healthier have
less alcoholism drug use suicide
and at the end of the day they control
more wealth when they die
yep okay interesting and all these
things are pushing
and they're happening they're happening
and at the same time women's
satisfaction in life has gone down
marriage rates have gone down divorce
rates are
you know going down but less so than
with the marriage rate so more people
are getting divorced
fertility is down childbirth is down
happiness is down
why it's not because we live in a world
that's like
horrible terrible place we live in a
world of abundance we have everything
that we want
this is the greatest time to be alive i
got i can't finish this thought
it's the greatest time to be alive but
these women are miserable
because they make more money they're
more educated they have more power than
they really want
and the pool of men available to them
diminishes with each step that they take
up the ladder
it is a self-defeating cycle that we can
all observe on the outside
and man i'm so glad we're talking about
this problem i've been writing about
this for 10 years
i'll make it simple it doesn't matter if
it's the men's fault
they want to write these studies and
they say men can't handle that women
make more money than them
it's like okay well that just means that
women still can't date the men
you can blame the men for it but if if a
woman wants to date a man
and she wants to find a good man and men
don't like this because you think they
can't handle it well then make a choice
do you want to date them or do you want
to adhere to what the man wants so it's
like
when you're in a relationship you don't
just dictate the relate you know you
don't say
you're dating me now that's it no every
relationship is are we providing
something to each other in some capacity
that makes us feel fulfilled that
relationship will work
if this story from the new york post
says that
you know these these women can't find
men who may make as much money as them
and then this other study says men can't
handle it well then it sounds like
it sounds like both parties are
dissatisfied by by all means say the men
are losers who can't handle it
okay that still means the one doesn't
get a date yeah so there we go it's an
impasse right well it's every
the system is flawed we we have just
continued we've just decided to just
and this is feminism this is so critical
race theory
this is sjw this is the whole thing
about the radical left
we have obliterated uh the differences
between men and women
in our minds and in our discourse but
you can't erase the biological
evolutionary differences that are built
into us
but but social influences as well that's
a big time because when you
when you remove the incentive to do
better to people then they'd
strive less to do better i've done my
best work for the most part when i
didn't have enough
and i needed to get more i needed i was
seeking that power once i get the power
i find that there's this tendency to sit
on my laurels to rest back and be like
now
you gotta work on that bro right so i
have to create like this outside
invisible uh enemy that i need to
overcome basically
with i love peterson's work he talks a
lot about this stuff i keep thinking
about it when we're talking about this
um so you know this whole social
structure where you have enough you have
everything government's going to take
care of you i think it's killing
incentives
i also think that you insult and demean
the maturity
and capabilities of 24 5 year old women
yeah absolutely there's no reason in the
world a mature
established 35 year old man cannot have
a healthy
productive fruitful relationship with a
woman 10 years younger than him
i didn't say that i just think you just
said they were immature and they
shouldn't be matched up 22.
okay 22 23 24. look they're women way
more college women mature way more
quickly than men dude
and that's way more questions
preferences at the age at age 15 women
they're basically women already
right and it's like men take men hit
their prime
in their 30s 35 why wouldn't a man in
his prime
latch on to a woman in her prime why not
that seems the most logical thing
possible that's what's happened for
millennia from millennia older men would
marry like 15 year olds
and the society the societal [ __ ] in
this society
around dating a younger woman is just
jealousy
it's jealousy because as you said every
man in the world wants to date a 22 year
old woman according to okcupid data
according to okay cupid i don't know
your own two eyes
all of history every piece of letter i'm
excited every book you ever saw because
it's not your opinion okay cupid
actually trapped
all the messages and they found no
matter how old a guy was from
even younger guys why do you think that
is always mentioning 22 year olds why do
you think that is for
i think by evolution like biological
reasons oh right exactly right and and
what
okcupid found was that very disgustingly
in my opinion men are actually attracted
to women much
much much younger than that but would
not want to have a family with someone
younger than that
so men choose 22 as the equilibrium
between mental and physical maturity
why is that disgusting there's nothing
there's nothing
wrong with little kids of course dude
well there's that there's that's
hyperbolic on my part right but there's
literally nothing wrong with seeing a
woman of fertile age
and thinking she is an attractive sexual
partner but like
acting on that with an 18 year old woman
is a completely different story
but there's nothing wrong with seeing an
18 year old girl woman
and being like oh she's attractive of
course she is she's in the prime
of her beauty 18. okay cupid data said
men want women younger than that
okay mom and that i find creepy yeah it
is because society
society has rules like it is creepy
today but guess what it wasn't creepy
until just recently i don't know
all of humanity all of history all the
time i still think it was creepy
i think i think i think a lot of past
cultures did a lot of really creepy
gross stuff
yeah of course of course and of course
i'm not advocating
for guys in their 30s sacrifice anyone
under 22. but i think it's perfectly
reasonable to have a relationship with a
woman who's in her early 20s
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you